you can't have everything you can have
what would be good for you but you have
to figure out what it is and then you
have to aim at it this is where a lot of
people fall down define prosperity by
your own terms
rise and shine
it's in spresso time good morning belief
nation it's evan my one word is believe
and i believe in you i believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that i want
to see exploded onto the world so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
setup criteria for success
over to you Jordan B Peterson one of the
main reasons that people do get what
they want is because they don't actually
figure out what it is and the
probability that you're going to get
what would be good for you let's say
which would even be better than what you
want right because you know you might be
what wrong about what you want easily
but maybe you could get what would
really be good for you well why don't
you well cuz you don't try you don't
think okay here's what I would like if I
could have it and and I don't mean I
don't mean in a way that you manipulate
the world to force it to deliver you
goods for status or something like that
that isn't what I mean I mean something
like imagine that you are taking care of
yourself like you were someone you
actually cared for and then you thought
okay I'm caring for this person I would
like things to go as well for them as
possible
what would their life have to be like in
order for that to be the case well
people don't do that they don't sit down
and think alright you know let's let's
figure it out you've got a life it's
hard obviously it's like three years
from now you can have what you need
you've got to be careful about it you
can't have everything you can have what
would be good for you but you have to
figure out what it is and then you have
to aim at it well my experience with
people as being is if they figure out
what it is that would be good for them
and then they aim at it then they get it
and it's strange because they don't mess
it sass strange thing it's not quite
that simple because you know you may
formulate an idea about what would be
good for you and then you take ten steps
towards that and you find out that your
formulation was a bit off and so you
have to reformulate your goal you know
you're kind of going like this as you
move towards the goal but a huge part of
the reason that people fail is because
they don't ever set up the criteria for
success and so since success is a very
narrow line and very unlikely the
probability that you're going to stumble
on it randomly is zero and so there's a
proposition here in the proposition is
if you actually want something you can
have it
now the question enema would be well
what do you mean by actually want and
the answer is that you reorient your
life in every possible way to make the
probability that that will occur as
certain as possible and that's a
sacrificial idea right it's like you
don't get everything obviously you
obviously but maybe you can have what
you need and maybe all you have to do to
get it is ask but asking isn't a whim or
today's wish it's like you have to be
deadly serious about it you have to
think okay like I'm taking stock of
myself and if I was going to live
properly in the world and I was going to
set myself up such that being would
justify itself in my estimation and I
don't mean as a harsh judge exactly what
is it that I would aim at sit on your
bed one day and ask yourself what's what
remarkably stupid things am i doing on a
regular basis to absolutely screw up my
life and if you actually ask that
question but you have to want to know
the answer right because that's actually
what asking the question means it
doesn't mean just mouthing the words it
means you have to decide that you want
to know you'll figure that's out so fast
it'll make your hair curl whenever you
set a goal for yourself you have to look
at your calendar and see if your actions
see if what you've allotted time for
matches up with your goals you have to
make sure that the actions that you take
on a consistent basis map to your
ambition so many times people go off and
set these crazy goals for themselves
which is awesome you want to have a big
goal that inspires you but then if you
look at their day-to-day actions you
look at their calendar you look at their
schedule nothing almost nothing of what
they're doing will actually lead them to
become successful and so whatever big
goal you have you then have to
reverse-engineer it to your calendar and
look at are the things that I'm doing on
a daily basis well those actions lead me
towards my goals and for most people
it's a big no I went to a Tony Robbins
event last year which was awesome I
brought Alex and Lily at
for my team here at TDS and everybody's
getting all riled up and excited in
rah-rah and motivated and and it was a
party and it's amazing the thing that's
going through my head is okay
Tony is challenging me to become a
better version of myself
Tony is challenging me to create a
better life for myself the immediate way
for me to figure that out is I need to
look at my calendar this better me that
I want to create and anything from being
an entrepreneur from being a better
husband from being a better father
all of these goals that I have for
myself then boom look at my calendar are
the things in my calendar allowing me to
be that better entrepreneur that better
husband that better son because if you
are not making the time for it guess
what it's not gonna happen cuz life will
get in the way and so you have to set
boundaries and you have to create it so
to allow you to go off and accomplish
your goals if you're doing multiple
things at the same time you have to
realize that your path might be a little
bit slower I had a great conversation
with Lilly last week from the unlocking
Lilly series and entrepreneur I've
invested in and she was frustrated with
the pace of growth of her business she
wanted to grow faster and you know first
off welcome to the world you know we all
want our businesses to go faster that's
that's life as an entrepreneur when we
first started together her challenge was
to become a speaker that's what she
wanted to do what she wanted to be a
speaker she wanted to take my
methodology of your one word and go off
to be a speaker since then it's evolved
where one she wants to keep being a
speaker - she wants to develop her own
material her own thought process her own
unique content instead of only using one
word content for me and three she wants
to be a coach
she likes the one-on-one interaction and
coaching people and helping guide them
through their process their issues and
so when you're trying to tackle three
things at the same time a speaker a
thought leader and a coach she's working
really really really hard if you look at
Lilly schedule you'll see that this
jam-packed full to make her better and
pursue her business but it's hard doing
three things at the same time it's great
to go off and do it but recognize that
your path is gonna be a little bit
slower because instead of doing one
thing and going all in on it you're
doing three things and trying to be the
best at all of them and so
path will be a little bit slower to
reach it and so whenever you set a goal
for yourself whether it's beginning of
the year whether you just get inspired
by this video whether it's a Monday
morning you know whenever it is that
you're sitting down and you're sitting
goals for yourself it's great to get
lost in that world of I feel so good
about this new future I'm going to
create for myself but then you have to
actually do the work and the work will
not just magically happen you've got to
factor it into your schedule whether
it's once a week once a day whatever
makes sense for you that should be the
biggest battle that you face of all is
how are you going to spend your time and
every time you add something in new that
takes away from something else there's
always an opportunity cost to your time
and so just make sure I really really
really really employ you because I think
this is where a lot of people fall down
they have the the one-off motivation
they have these big goals and ambitions
and desires and dreams and what they
want to do but they never follow through
on it because they don't have the
schedule that allows them to because
they're doing a lot of activities that
don't map to their ambition so if you
look at your schedule you look at where
you're spending your time and put in
your family and put in all of the
personal stuff you want to do as well
look at how you're spending your time in
your calendar if you keep doing these
actions will it take you to where you
want to go and if not you have to start
adjusting those actions and make your
calendar better now I've got a special
bonus clip for you guys but before that
the question of the day I have for you
is what is one immediate change that you
need to make to your calendar so that it
will better map to your ambitions leave
it down in the comments below I'm really
curious to hear from you thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of an espresso and enjoy the bonus
so give me
so when you ask the question or when we
look at the question how do I create a
life of prosperity when I haven't known
it when my family hasn't known it
it's not what we're it's not what I was
born into you know there many people was
born who are born into prosperity I
wasn't one and you may or may not be one
but how you transform a life or create
lacking prosperity is number one you
identify what does prosperity look like
to you define prosperity by your own
terms and don't make it a global
Universal answer you want to define
prosperity in each area of your life I
know that sounds like there's really
detail but you cannot hit a moving
target you won't ever hit a movie talk
so the more detail you get the more the
target slows down
the sponsors of Robert Smith's career
only did so after I demonstrated that
I'm willing to make the commitment to my
career it's a two-way street it's not
just oh here's you know the person
you're gonna sponsor make sure that they
get on good deals no it is they see you
in the office your grind in a hundred
hours you're getting it done you're you
know you're making sure there's no
mistakes and if there is a mistake you
correct it you're following up you're
reaching outside of your knowledge to go
learn more when you do that sponsors are
more than happy to then take credit for
you
okay and that has been my experience but
it has all come through you got it you
got a you got to demonstrate that that's
who you are and that's your priority if
it's Friday night and it's five o'clock
your response we're seeing you leaving
cuz you got you know happy hour with
with your boys well guess what I mean
and they're there you know you got to be
conscious of that that sort of stuff
okay I like when they come back in on
Saturday because they did come back and
I'm wearing the same thing I wore Friday
night right okay this guy's dedicated to
his crowd and so when this deal happens
they're happy to stand up and from the
managing principal of the firm at that
time to say hey you know Robert did this
work you see I mean so it's a two-way
street and sponsors you know again I
have the opportunity and I do in my firm
and build and develop people but we have
when we do our reviews part of what
we're looking at you have that kind of
grit and you dedicated to this Craig
this is not a lifestyle business and if
you want to make it a lifestyle business
this is wrong business to be in okay so
that's in the world I live in that's
something we think about we talk about
in that context that's just day trip so
we look for you know again I will
sponsor those and even my folks now who
have not grown up with me in this
business I sponsored them because I saw
them putting that level of effort and
energy and 15 years ago and guess what
they still do it today raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
values
is that we believe that people with
passion can change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on your
that's something sue me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details